so you want to make a deadly competition
film well you came to the right place
people seem to have a strange
fascination with watching groups of
people sometimes children murder each
other on the big screen so pay attention
as I teach you how to exploit this
sub-genre and rake in the big box first
off you need your characters they should
all have strange names Frankenstein
Cleopatra Oh pizza I mean come on no one
really wants to see a guy named Mike get
brutally murdered there are three types
of people that need to be in your film
number one the ringleader this is the
person that controls the entire
competition they call the shots although
you might be able to get by with casting
this character as a woman or a Japanese
guy you will have much better luck going
with a white male number two the psycho
while most of the characters are
scrambling and killing to stay alive
this guy murders for fun he is one
twisted motherfucker that you do not
want to mess with it just killed
somebody
number three the helpless one this is
the character you just can't help but
feel bad for he or she might have a
weapon but they definitely don't know
how to use it they are essentially
powerless and can do nothing to prevent
their certain doom once you have a
character's you have to place them in
the game but what are the games you may
ask basically they can be any location
where people can be forced to kill each
other such as a racetrack a jungle a
roller rink or a blown-out city you can
give the games a set of rules but the
ringleader should always change them at
the last moment dramatically affecting
the end of your film so why should this
one be any different controls you you're
going to need an explanation for why the
games are happening and the answer to
that question should always be the
government whether it's to stop a
rebellion cut down on inmates or the
prisons or discipline teenagers the game
should always be government approved
blood remind your audience and Slayers
was put together with the full
cooperation and approval of the United
States federal government and so it was
decreed one young man and woman to fight
to the death once more
I give you what you want this
information can be relied through text
at the beginning of your film
the US prison system reaches a breaking
point or on a television spot slater's
Slayers the brothers die through others
welcome to Deborah do you want to get
fancy you can even include both I think
it's our tradition it comes out of a
particularly painful part of our history
yeah speaking of television these games
should be covered by all media outlets
and cheered on by massive crowds of fans
it doesn't matter the normal people
would not be okay with watching people
die for fun your fictional fans are
crazy slow new tics that just love to
watch bloodshed once you're in the
production of your film pay special
attention to the camerawork a little
over 10 years ago it was all right to
shoot your movie on a tripod and have
beautiful dolly shots you're allowed to
film an image and not manipulate the
color to death but honestly where the
fuck would you want to do that literally
the only way to engross audience members
in an intense scene is to include a
massive camera shake I'm not talking
about Cloverfield shakiness that bits
for boobies I'm talking about
Parkinson's meets epilepsy shakiness I
want you to hurl after the first 15
seconds of viewing it it'll really add
dread to the picture and finally what
would a deadly competition film be
without death make sure you include an
immensely enormous Lee colossal amount
of death lots and lots of death
and that's it follow these simple
instructions and you'll be on your way
to making your very own deadly
competition film